wissenschaftler knacken den
fingerabdruck revolutionen in der
meeresforschung und affen lernen eine
fremdsprache diese und weitere themen
gibt es jetzt in den krieg zum fluss
fingerabdruck entschlüsselt mathematiker
aus den usa konnten ein modell
entwickelt mit dem man nun
fingerabdrücke und zwar deren entstehung
nachvollziehen kann die forscher des
benutzten dafür eine form der
sogenannten swift hohenberg gleichung
diese beschreibt das physikalische
verhalten von zweilagigen gewölbten
materialien der menschliche finger
spielt nämlich im mutterleib an kleine
gewebe polster plänen den finger auf und
wenn das kind dann geboren wird geht
diese schwellung zurück und ähnlich wie
eine traube die zu rosine wird bilden
sich dann die falten die wir als
fingerabdruck kennen mit dieser formel
kann man auch nachvollziehen dass zwei
identische fingerabdrücke extrem
unwahrscheinlich sind mit einer chance
von 1 achtung zu zehn milliarden haben
zwei menschen die gleichen fingerabdruck
untersuchungen der weltmeere jahrzehnte
lang wurden die tiere der tiefsee
untersucht indem man sie schlicht und
einfach gefangen hat dazu musste man
aufwendig netze auswerfen oder sogar mit
einem u-boot abtauchen doch eine
verblüffend einfache methode soll die
meeresforschung nun revolutionieren
an der meeresoberfläche befindet sich
nämlich nahezu unendlich viel dns von
fast allen kreaturen die mehr leben mit
einer wasserprobe und einem modernen
labor können die einzelnen tierarten die
in der nähe leben identifiziert werden
bei den ersten test durchlaufen wurde
die gefundenen dns mit einer datenbank
verglichen
das unglaubliche ergebnis gerade einmal
drei prozent der proben sind in der
datenbank überhaupt vorhanden den nach
stangen stammen die meisten der
eingesammelten proben von tieren die der
wissenschaft noch überhaupt nicht
bekannt sind dass die tiere schon lange
ausgestorben sind und die
wissenschaftler nur alte reste
identifiziert haben kann übrigens
ausgeschlossen werden
nach ungefähr einer woche werden die dns
proben unlesbar unsere ozeane geben uns
also fast so viele rätsel wie unser
universum
affen können fremdsprachen lernen
forscher der universität zürich haben
nun herausgefunden dass affen ihre
sprache anpassen und sogar in der lage
sind wörter eines anderen affen stammes
zu erlernen
nachdem holländische und schottische
schimpansen gruppen in einem zoo
zusammengeführt wurden änderte sich der
schrei für apfel gefunden in beiden
gruppen hörbar der schrei der
schimpansen aus holland wurde über 200
hertz tiefer um sich den tieferen
schottischen schrei anzupassen
das ist der erste hinweis dafür dass
eine andere spezies ihre kommunikation
aktiv an soziale veränderungen anpasst
wenn ihr euch selber mal die schreie der
affen übrigens anhören wollt in der
video beschreibung ist ein ding rosetta
unternimmt sturzflug auf den kometen
nachdem die raumsonde rosetta vor rund
drei monaten die landeeinheit philae
erfolgreich abgesetzt hat soll der komik
show room of gerasimenko weiter
untersucht werden dafür wird die
raumsonde ein paar spektakuläre
flugmanöver ausführen darunter auch ein
sturzflug der den kometen möglichst
knapp verfehlen soll um daten ein
zusammen wie ihr hier sehen können wird
rosetta in den kommenden wochen viele
blickwinkel auf den kometen erhalten
dabei soll besonders der mysteriöse
kometenschweif mit allen vorhandenen
instrumenten untersucht werden bei den
untersuchungen kommt die raumsonde auf
bis zu 6 kilometer an den kometen heran
über den verlauf der mission werden wir
euch natürlich hier auf dem kanal und
auf klicks um de informieren
blauwale sind faszinierende tiere mit
bis zu 33 metern länge und einer masse
von bis zu 200 tonnen sind fünf super
schwere lkw sind sie die größten und
gleichzeitig schwersten bekannten
lebewesen die jemals auf der erde gelebt
haben nun haben forscher aus san diego
einen engen verwandten der blauwale den
finnwal genauer untersucht sie scannten
den schädel eines angeschwemmten finnwal
und modellierten diesen exakt am
computer nach mit diesem modell konnten
die wissenschaftler herausfinden dass
die tiere schallwellen mit ihrem
schädelknochen wahrnehmen also nicht mit
den ohren
die extrem tiefen frequenzen mit denen
wahl über 1000 m
mit der entfernung kommunizieren können
nur vom schädel aufgenommen werden der
wie eine antenne fungiert die neuen
erkenntnisse könnten zur änderung in der
gesetzgebung führen damit war nicht mehr
durch unterwasserlärm gestört und
desorientiert werden das meer wird
übrigens nicht nur von uns bezahlt
sondern auch schrecklich verschmutzt so
sehr sogar dass in hongkong das wasser
anfängt zu leuchten
mehr zu diesem thema erwarte in der
letzten ausgabe der top five news dazu
da oben klicken zu rap und zum blog geht
es wie immer alle links und mehr infos
natürlich in der video beschreibung
genau und was meint ihr
welche tierarten verstecken sich noch in
dem tier mit tiefen tiefen der weltmeere
wie sehen sie aus vielleicht so war
schreibe es in die kommentare und wie
immer bis dann bleibt dran